(chill rock)
- Kinda like a skater has a skateboard,
or a BMXer has a bike,
I just saw the wheelchair
as something fun,
so why not take it into the park?
I'm Aaron "Wheelz" Fotheringham
and I ride WCMX.
WCMX stands for Wheelchair Motocross.
It's, you know, taking your chair
into the skate park and hitting ramps.
Kind of the same thing as
BMX, but with a wheelchair.
I first started going to the skate parks
when I was eight years old.
And I've been doing it for 16 years now.
The wheelchair's definitely
just an extension of my body,
because skaters aren't
always on their skateboard,
and bikers aren't always on their bike,
but I'm always on my chair.
So that gives me like an unfair advantage
to just practice everywhere I go.
I feel like I'm lucky that I always
have my wheelchair with me, 'cause I can
just jump whenever I want.
I was born with spina bifida.
I've had 21 surgeries throughout my life.
And I spent a lot of
time in the hospitals.
And yeah, it would be easy to
just be bummed out on that,
but I was, for me, I
just found the positive.
The wheelchair's just
always been fun, and,
it's wheels, stuck to your butt.
How's that not a great time?
(wonderous music)
In 2008, I got the Guinness World Record
for the first back flip on a wheelchair.
And that was at a local competition
here in Vegas called Am-Jam.
That was a pretty cool day.
One of my favorite tricks
is just a simple hand plant.
Because I always loved watching skaters
do it when I was growing up, and, you know,
watching the pros do it,
it just was something
I wanted to learn.
I'm very blessed to be
able to do what I love
and what I'm passionate
about for a living.
A lot of the time, the wheelchair comes
with the stereotype of "you can't do this"
or whatever, because
it's a medical device.
I just always think the
wheelchair's a great opportunity.
(simple tones)